la posizione iniziale che avete visto
quando è partito sto video è esattamente
la posizione in cui sto quando mi faccio
i cazzi miei e guardo il computer quindi
metti solo un attimo quel frame iniziale
jean mettilo in questo momento deve far
vedere esatto questo fra questa e la
questa è la posizione sta e la posizione
che voi non dovete assumere mai perché
poi la schiena è un casino infatti io
davanti ai ragazzi oggi faccio fido un
po particolare perché vi spiego
l'esistenza di un canale mio segreto che
nessuno conosce molte cose non le posso
far vedere perché sono magari contenuti
un po troppo oltre il family friendly
però analizzando il montaggio
sicuramente una cosa ci esce e voglio
vedere perché poi c'è da un sacco di
tempo contro canale tipo da cinque anni
vediamo ora esatta che cosa dovrebbe
essere oggi siamo su ei io comunque di
problemi mentali ne avevo mi sono
rimasti
ma per chi va per questo casino fai la
chicca 360 allo scopo workshop vediamo
cosa non mi ricordo non solo hanno fatto
davvero io a questa non era non era
neanche così bella e vanta però ok
allora questo è uno dei pochissimi video
pubblici che ci sono questo canale senza
averlo mai bocciato la niente affatto
130.000 views perché era molto
divertente per chi conosce warcraft ci
sono questi siano peony warcraft iii e
ci sono stipendi che che servono per
creare le strutture che quando li crei
da loro frasi in italiano è pronto per
lavoro questo lo dico è in inglese
berton hulk ok quindi io ho preso il
ready to work campionato del peone e ci
ho fatto la canzone rehab 6 secondi
questo era il video non ve l'ho fatto
sentire tutto per quanto siano solo otto
secondi perché quando e marco piantato
non me lo voglio peccare anche in questo
video e copia equa ero io che avevo
provato a fare una traccia di martin
garics vfl studio
vi sta cosa qua ragazzi l'ho fatta io va
bene niente di che era targata però ero
io che tentavo di creare canzoni c'è
stato un periodo in cui entrai per la
parola complimenti per la vita da però
ragazzi c'è
[Musica]
non è male se ci pensate che io non ho
mai fatto niente c'è questa è l'unica
cosa che ho fatto e per farlo ci ho
messo era il mio primo approccio fl
studio minuscola ma niente male
avrei avuto un futuro però mi sono dato
i video di youtube ma è questa era tipo
una registrazione in 360
credo non so se si vede in 360 si vede
in 360
[Risate]
bellissimo anche l'ora è bellissimo
vabbè comunque stavo provando a vedere
se funziona altre 60 sul lg fichissimo
lau squad the state
questa non me lo ricordo sono quattro
anni paoli
affacciato cazzo ma ricordavo dai rega
finissimo minchia fin troppo voglia di
giocarsi c'è di giocarci giocarci un
cazzo si sono di visionare che grande
siamo lo ricordava benissimo
ma cosa non farebbe benissimo
i copyright a lo spero
non hanno gridato scarlino
[Applauso]
[Musica]
vorrei vedere il drop
[Applauso]
è la giardino bellissimo mi chiama
ricordavo questa di giuro su dio
bellissimo norica fantastico
è questa la parte
cavolo bello ma vorrei che l'anci ma non
è facile non è perché
non lo saprei neanche più fare sta roba
si chiamano dice de luca
[Musica]
vai vai l'offensiva io trovo di seguirla
dovrà sentire ma chiami tutto non lo so
se ho fatto meno rea
[Musica]
la vedrà
bravo cacchio bravo bravo ragazzo
questo video di quando avevo 0 anni e
strappava un fazzoletto non era un senso
in realtà però vabbè per rendere fatta
cosa fare falli derapata cosa stai
facendo madama che boys crack ha appunto
cercavamo apriranno batteri gram e
qualcuno aveva investito qualcun altro
non porterà alcun era andata addosso a
qualcun altro con la macchina tipo ecco
madonna
dice che volta e poi poi qualcuno ha
detto è decollato tipo nuova miss a
madonna bellissimo vice di ricordi a
allo star bari svegliato carbox piano
che pensavo avesse fa pensavo avrebbe
fatto molto di più perché era il periodo
in cui andavano tanto ri in emesso dal
tar era anche impegnato buonissimo
perfetta ho qua sta iniziando anno che
si aspetta che vi fa cedere questa festa
festa peggio ancora rolling stone
quest'area dark souls semplicemente io
in un livello questo l'ho giocato per i
fatti miei
dovevo veloso nella scala arriva st
pietra mi colpisce e mi fa un danno
bestiale vabbè faccio per andar via mi
ri colpisce la stessa pietra emiri
colpisce di nuovo uccidendo me la stessa
pietra mi ha colpito tre volte la stessa
noi che dici tra pietro e la stessa
pietra mi ha colpito tre volte nei
ucciso questo signore e signori è dark
souls questi sono video dove io spiego a
giampiero come montare i video e quindi
in mezzo sto video come montare un
horror dove io che mi metto a montarla
vi faccio vedere come montare il gioco
divertente però non troppissimo perché
ci sono perché gli stili di montaggi
diversi rispetto agli horror rispettivi
divertenti ci sono gli stili diversi
perché gli horror vanno a tenuta più
atmosfera i video più divertenti puoi
fare un po più di tagli però deve far
ridere tutto sempre invece l'oro di chi
guarda ora vuole l'atmosfera decise dei
video che è una via di mezzo quello che
è divertente come video ma non troppi
simo gli archetti o altro fisico cose
incredibili
yepp è semplicemente una caduta rovinosa
fatta su un mega sussistere in red dead
redemption questa un altro video
caricato pubblico perché roberto
successe cose pazzesche e tipo questa
iniziati a volare mi cavallo poi ha dato
una testata al soffitto invisibile
fantastico questo signore signori e
pubblico e secondo me meritava e onidi
views ed è il nonno lee jean pierre un
giorno mi ha fatto vedere il suo video
ripreso suo nonno mentre loro spaventa e
poi sono lì dice fatti i fatti tuoi
e io sotto ci ho messo il mood di di
oblivion o skyrim perché sono anno
alimos senza volerlo ha fatto le movenze
esatte di skyrim che guarda te ne so io
l'audio di skyrim perfetto
sono incredibilmente alla mimica di
skyrim fantastico e questo è l'ultimo di
una settimana fa
che magari avete già visto da instagram
prego
tanto sbagliato correction perché qua e
in un modo e qui è tutta gialla sono
dato a montepulciano che molti pensano
che la scena di twilight sia stato
girato a volterra in realtà è stato
girato a montepulciano perché volte
erano li ha dati per messina e genova è
comunque sono andato là e ho fatto sto
video a voi dice una settimana fa per
questo video lo sto registrando un sacco
di tempo prima comunque montepulciano è
bellissima mamma come tutta la toscana
in realtà quindi niente ragazzi questo
era il mio canale segreto inutile che
andate a cercarlo tanto non carica non
mai roma pubblica forse però tutto
quello che ho caricato finora velo fatto
vedere se poi tra tipo 45 anni farò di
nuovo questo video ecco tutta la roma
nuova caricata in questi anni
signori quindi iscritti al canale non
quelle schede a questo che certo tasto
mi piace servì dove piaciuto spiace da
campani ha prima danneggiato i suoi
video e noi come sempre ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo video della ragazza
[Musica]